[Musik]
hallo meine lieben mein traum war es
schon immer ein eigenheim für meine
familie zu bauen
eine küche in der ich meine videos
drehen und rezepte entwickeln kann ein
ort an welchem ich mit meinen eltern
zusammen wohnen weil es mir einfach auch
wichtig ist dass meine kinder mit oma
und opa groß werden
meine mitarbeiter sind meine freunde und
mit ihnen arbeiten wir bei uns zu hause
jeder hat sein eigenes aufgabengebiet
werden videos geschnitten grafiken
entwickelt produkte entworfen bücher
erstellt möbel und messestände gebaut
do it yourself videos gedreht und vieles
vieles mehr
wir haben einen ort erschaffen an dem
wir uns alle wohl fühlen
samira und ella sind jetzt alt genug und
möchten gerne wissen wie alles mit
unserem haus angefangen hat samira el a
wir erzählen euch heute wie und warum
wir unser haus gebaut haben
[Musik]
jetzt im alex und auch eine art passage
zu machen ich zum beispiel holz
bekleidung war ich klar ist da alex das
macht weil er alex ist zimmermanns
meister und ich glaube wenn du was
anderes gemacht hätte wäre ich
enttäuscht gewesen
der vorteil ist bei so einer holzfassade
ist natürlich die ist eigentlich
günstiger
die ist günstiger als einzige ding ist
hatten sich intensiv und alex silvas
gedacht haben dabei ja wartungsintensiv
der hinsicht war die wetterseiten sind
beratungsintensiver ja muss man einfach
auch das süd west ausrichtung her
und ja da muss man eben darauf achten
dass man da öfter nach streicht hier in
der nordsee ost seite reicht es
eigentlich jeden fall mit zehn jahren
ihr sohn beim alexander terrasse und
hier siehst du natürlich auch das ist
sich auf der terrasse der schatten
erreicht hier sieht es noch die
sibirische lärche was ein sehr sehr
witterungsbeständig des holzes was ich
bei mir eine außenfassade auch habe sie
ist natürlich was über ein jahr
passierten das holz nicht behandelt und
zwar jetzt will ich hier von der
sibirischen typischen gleichen farbe
geht es dann langsam ins vertraute das
muss man wirklich mögen viele mögen es
nicht manche mögen's aber wie gesagt und
wichtiges erste holz und behandelt wir
haben bei uns einer fassade eine
farblose lasur gemacht deswegen wird es
bei mir irgendwann auch vertrauen aber
nicht so schnell
[Musik]
sie haben wir zum beispiel eine
klinkerfassade das ist eigentlich von
mir so ein absoluter traum klingt da
finde ich richtig schön und zwar sind es
auch diese richtigen echten steinen
ringofen klinker heißes ganze das wird
auch in einer charge dann gebrannt aber
natürlich hat man hier einmal den hohen
aufwand denn jeder stein muss wirklich
einzeln an die fassade dran gemacht
werden man natürlich auch dadurch höhere
kosten und es war einfach viel zu
zeitintensiv und ihn so recht sagen also
bei unserem gebäude das wäre
wahrscheinlich hätte unseren kompletten
finanziellen rahmen gesprengt
hier aber ist es richtig schön hier sind
ja gerade beim firmengebäude von der
firma griff und die fassaden einfach
immer ganz unterschiedlich also jeder
stein wird ganz anders aus und ich finde
es dann richtig besonderen charme
gerade im norden und in holland habe ich
das schon ganz oft gesehen sehr schön
jetzt sehen wir natürlich bei der
gängigsten fassade dies in deutschland
nicht üblich in flaschen sagen 70 bis 80
prozent der leute in deutschland wie
verputzen hier raus und ich habe gesagt
das verputzen was ganz ganz wie soll ich
sagen was high class ist da musst du
wirklich einfach betrieb nehmen und
leider behaupten manche werden
fachbetriebe sind meistens aber nicht
und fahrrad putzen das günstigste neues
problem mehr verputzen ist dass du
vielleicht alle 10 15 jahre an seiner
fassade dran muss wieder ein gerüst
stellen wieder farbe drauf und das koste
jedes mal geld und kann die fassade ist
acht jahre alt geworden mein bruder und
es ist schon komplett ausgeglichen
du siehst auch noch mal hier und was du
aussiehst hier diese verschmutzung und
das heißt die fassade ist erst 18 jahre
alt das ist ein haus noch relativ neu
aber hier muss schon wieder richtig
etwas gemacht werden
richtig stark was gemacht werden und
wieder gerüst hoch und das ganze haus
einzurüsten kurs natürlich auch geld und
es war auch einer der gründe warum wir
uns gegen putz entschieden haben und ihr
müsst euch mal wenn ich eins machen
nimmt doch mal die zeit läuft man durch
die neubaugebiete und schaut euch mal
die verputzten fassade an ihr findet
überall irgendwelche aus gleichungen ich
keine risse oder was sie was ganz extrem
ist das könnte man hier sehen
hier siehst du zum beispiel dieses netz
schon
und deswegen haben wir uns gegen eine
putzfassade entschieden weil wir einfach
nicht alle zehn jahre hin gehen wollen
und wieder die fassade wieder reparieren
und wieder wieder aufrüsten möchten und
hier wieder diese tropft nasen meistens
ist es da beim dachvorsprung oder
wirklich an diesen lampen
an der wand hängen dass es hier so rund
läuft und dann diese verschmutzungen
verursachen
auch diese kanten hier diese abbrüche
und die müssen wir jetzt alles nochmal
verputzen nochmal vermitteln und dessen
zu sachen wo man sagt boah wahnsinn und
deswegen dreht ja ich habe dann einfach
mal angeschrieben weil ich habe was
nachhaltiges gesucht und natürlich auch
wie wenig kosten ich bin ja strafe und
dann habe ich eigentlich jetzt ja dann
wirklich zwei wochen glaubt gebrauch
bisher geantwortet hat ja aber das
lustige war als ich mit ihm telefoniert
habe habe ich einen dialekt gehört erst
schwabe und dann wusste ich das ist der
richtige mann für uns
ich habe eine mail bekommen von von
verrat und abgelesen dass es um die
sally geht und kleine geschichte aus dem
privaten bereich meine frau beschäftigt
sich seit einiger zeit mit der sie packt
auch sehr gerne verfolgt die sally und
der erste gedanke war jetzt verfolgt
mich dieser stelle auch im
geschäftlichen bereich also für uns als
brief aber eigentlich relativ schnell
klar dass wir mit jura zusammenarbeiten
möchten wir hatten nach diesem mail
einen persönlichen kontakt mit beiden
es war alles sehr locker aus der lockere
atmosphäre familiäre atmosphäre
nachdem die auswahl dann auf den seiten
gefallen ist man natürlich die frage wer
montiert die fassade und da ist
üblicherweise so dass sally und murat
einen bekannten im freundeskreis haben
der einen eigenen handwerksbetrieb
betreibt und wir haben ihn dann an die
hand genommen haben ihn umfangreich und
intensiv geschult in unserer treffer
hätte mir ja und dann habe ich natürlich
die bauleitung der fassade genommen und
habe dann den alex angewiesen was er zu
tun hat gut gemacht
ich hatte den ganzen baum griff okay
weil ich so haben geholfen so jetzt
immer mit dem alex zusammen hier bei uns
eine garage und wir haben für euch jetzt
mal was vor gerichtet hergerichtet vor
gerichtet wie auch immer und hier wollte
man anhand eines modell beispiel sich
zeigen wie so eine fassadenverkleidung
bei uns jetzt bei uns daheim es findet
sich wie so eine fassadenverkleidung bei
uns zu hause aussieht und zwar ihr habt
ja wenn du die anderen medien verfolgt
habt wir haben ja eine torwand und zwar
normalerweise haben wir 36
und hier haben ohne 15 da waren jetzt
nur so zu zu versuchszwecken das wäre
zum beispiel zum beispiel und das ist
eine ganz normale thomas tolle band ist
wir müssen nicht mehr zusätzlich kämen
und jetzt kommt der erste schritt bei
der anbringung der fassade und zwar
machen wir unsere mannschaft genau wann
zahlungsplan machen so hoffen
genau das geht ganz ganz einfach wir
hätten jetzt noch mal dran den leuten
mal zeigen wie so etwas aussieht aber
richtig befestigt wird sie dann durch
die später unterkonstruktion des actions
by our die unterfunktion an
[Musik]
und jetzt schrauben es einfach fest
[Applaus]
die wand zahlungsplan machen wir nicht
einfach nur drauf weil es einem spaß
macht das hat auch seine gründe
die wahlentscheidung sbahn macht man
eigentlich auch rein oder drauf wegen
der windrichtung und zwei müssen wir
verstehen und mauerwerk lässt auch mal
luft durch das heißt wenn ich dass es
sich gemacht hätte oder auch gar nicht
verputzen oder gar nichts machen würde
wird der wind wirklich durch die ritzen
pfeifen deswegen machen wir hier
diese diese waren darauf was wir jetzt
im alex auch machen ist dieses
lüftungsgeräten rein damit hier einfach
keine ungeziefer reinkommen so wie zum
beispiel ratten oder oder irgendwelchen
wild mäuse so kleine feldmäuse oder
hasen oder irgendwas stören könnte
[Musik]
damit jetzt auch schöne waren wir auch
dieses sockel blick darauf wie ist der
name schon sagt ist es der sockel
abschluss
[Musik]
als nächstes haben wir hier es ist kein
gymnastik oder yoga wand und zwar ist es
eine epdm bahn um mit dieser idee m bahn
tun wir einen brunnen holz norma
schützen zusätzlich und packen es
einfach drauf lassen es ein bisschen
über hängen weil er kommt nachher unsere
britta fassade drüber und packendes und
jetzt machen wir unsere sechs panels hin
ganz einfach
[Musik]
und hier einfach einsetzen fertigung um
wieder fest bord
[Musik]
normalerweise kommt jetzt noch hier oben
attika black drauf ist jetzt kein könnt
und hier lauf läuft nachher das wasser
designs panels natürlich runter und es
war es und es cool ist natürlich habe
ich ja schon mal erwähnt bei jedem an
ihrer stunde sie teure passade anders
aus jetzt 40 jahre garantie drauf und es
war auch einer der gründe warum ich mich
dafür entschieden habe weil ich einfach
nicht alle 10 15 jahre lang an der
fassade was machen möchte ich mache das
einmal in meinem leben und macht danach
nie mehr wieder was dran
und was ich auch ganz ganz wichtig wenn
wir in anderen aspekt gehen wir mal noch
über über den umweltaspekt alex der ist
auch ganz ganz wichtig vielleicht wird
jetzt ein und vielleicht schreiben ja
aber beim aluminium bei der
aluminiumherstellung wird sehr viel
energie verwendet stimmen wirklich die
aluminium herstellung verbraucht
wirklich extrem viel energie
dort drehte arbeitet hier mit dem
sekundären aluminium dh dieses alle
mögen wir schon wurde schon mehrmals
recycelt und was ist ganz ganz wichtig
ist wenn ihr später mal ein haus wieder
abreißt sozusagen ich mein ich weiß ich
baue ich ein haus will ich jetzt weiß
ich seit 40 jahren wieder ab ich werde
das nicht mehr tun aber vielleicht meine
kinder werden irgendwann das haus
abreißen und das haus muss recycelt
werden
wir haben gesehen wir haben wir überall
lösbare verbindungen dh wenn das haus
nachher wieder wie soll ich dann
abgerissen wird dann machen wir die
panels weg dann machen wir das holz weg
dann macht man hier den dem schutzzweck
und die steine sind alle separat zu
recyceln das ist das geniale das ist
keine wie soll ich sagen eine
untrennbare verbindung was nur meinem
normalen mauerwerk natürlich ist da ist
die dämmung mit mit mit der band
verbunden dann kommt noch mal ein
mineral putz darunter und das ist nun
sein und dann kommt noch netz reinkommen
kunststoff rein und das ist ganz ganz
einfach zu recyceln und wie gesagt mit
dem sekundären aluminium wahnsinn
ich hoffe ich konnte jetzt auf die
schneller klären jetzt gemacht wurde und
machen weiter ein video
bis gleich
[Musik]
was von beginn an ein sehr wichtiges
thema für sally und murat waren war die
nachhaltigkeit das nachhaltige bauen
nachhaltigkeit heißt man kann es recycle
zu 100 prozent das ist und ich habe die
ganze zeit bei was meine rechnung ist
meine rechnung ist ganz einfach denn es
ging alles hätte die aluminiumpreise
jetzt der tagespreis in 30 jahren wird
sie aluminium oder 40 jahren mit die
aluminiumfassade noch mehr wert sein
weil es ja der rohstoff ist das heißt
ich bekomme vielleicht das gleiche geld
wieder in 40 jahren zurück was ich jetzt
gerade investiert haben wahnsinn solch
in schwaben sehr nachhaltiges produkt
wir haben mit aluminium einen sehr
wertvollen recycelbaren werkstoff der zu
100 prozent recycelbar ist ohne
qualitätseinbußen und in der in der
gesamtbetrachtung eine sehr sehr
positive ökobilanz aufweisen auch das
gewicht ist nicht von der hand zu weisen
wenn es um das thema transport gebe es
ist eine sprache ist die ganzen
aufgefallen dass das schwieger gerade
die ganze schule wäre ja wahnsinn
er läuft hier einfach ist mit training
wirklich in hollywood film und papa
läuft einfach mit seiner bundfalten
wohnen sind ein händler wahnsinn
[Musik]
ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie stark ich
wirklich bin okay da schaffe ich 50 oder
so und dann geht es immer besser
das soll nicht sein aber ich kann nur
rolle vorwärts aber nicht auf der
baustelle ist gefährlich
[Musik]
für uns war es sehr wichtig dass die
sally hinter unserem produkt und der
marke besteht und somit gelingt es hier
auch dieses produkt dieses technische
produkt auf eine authentische und
sympathische art zu ihren zuschauern zu
transportieren und sie ebenfalls von
unseren produkten zu begeistern
viele meiner zuschauer haben ja schon
gefragt wegen der alu fassade ob die
dann details wird und dadurch eben an
das hausinnere heiß wird also klar wenn
man jetzt die alle platten hier vorne
liegen haben unter der prallen sonne
werden sind natürlich sehr heiß am haus
hat mir die direkte sonneneinstrahlung
nicht so wie jetzt hier auf dem boden
natürlich wird die fassade waren aber
man hat ja die belüftung hinten also
oben offenen unten offen die luft
zirkuliert daher bleibt die wärme auch
schon draußen und ungeziefer zum
beispiel das war nämlich auch die frage
ob sich da nicht ungeziefer hinteren
sammelt aber es ist ja so bewerber in
einem raum steht der auf durchzug ist
also vorne offen hinten tür offen und da
fühlt man sich ja auch nicht so wohl und
deswegen fühlen sich hier auch
ungeziefer und westen zum beispiel licht
holt die kommen zweiten rein aber gehen
wir da unten raus kommen wir hatten
eigentlich serie eingestellt also sofort
einstellen das wirklich handwerklich
total begabt ja und der moratti war dem
urlaub oder dieser mütze genau wie auf
der baustelle gesehen ist aber glaube ja
besser so die habe ich mal weg
gescheucht die ganze zeit und da muss
ich dauernd dieses zeugnis ab gesteht
nach morgens zusammen gesammelt und hat
es dann in die kiste rein gemacht und
die werde ich jetzt ein schrotthändler
geben weil dies ja was wert ansonsten
nicht gegrillt haben sie mit wasser
versorgt
und der mich dauernd weggeschickt weiß
aber nicht warum das sieht man dem buch
hat kann auch mehr als nur müll
aufräumen
er kann auch ja es kommen alle pause auf
murat ist haben alle hunger yahoo
dann bleibt draußen stehen wenn er
genauso schafe wird wie er später wird
das haus schon längst fertig sagt mein
papa auch immer
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ein bisschen herz auf der kippe
[Applaus]
kekse ist
[Musik]
heute ist ein historischer tag alex ja
wir bauen das letzte panel rand der
fassade und dann ist die fassade fertig
jawohl wir haben es geschafft den 600 61
606 wo mein gott es reicht ist
eigentlich so ein stempel jetzt noch
drauf
du warst das letzte stück im lippenstift
kurs nicht ganz geschafft jetzt kann
endlich das gerüst weg
also es gibt immer mal sachen im bau wo
man sagt das will ich anders machen
das kommt bei jedem vor nein ich fenster
mit meinem freund bestellen aber die
fassade aber die fassade durch zu 100
prozent doch nun machen wo sie jetzt
unser haus von außen aus und wer uns
dafür entschieden dass wir hier auf der
südseite als auf der sonnenseite einfach
doch ein bisschen holz machen was
ansonsten ja wert so einseitig genau
einfach ein akzent zu setzen werden aber
wir haben es einfach auch das ist auch
hier besser geschützt aber trotzdem
obwohl ist die holzfassade gerade mal
vier monate dran ist haben wir schon
gemerkt dass du wirklich alle halbe jahr
musst du einmal drüber streiten zwei mal
im jahr muss du drauf streichen
eigentlich anders gemacht hast du ein
paar jung und fit bleibt habe ich immer
ein bisschen arbeit jeder farbe
streichen verbleibs thema fit immer fit
herbst an englisch zu tür genau und so
ist es einfach cool aus das ganze haus
denke ja ohne immer so richtig wohl ohne
finde es auch schön genauem hatte auf
der b36 fährt und dann soll hier her
schaut gerne stellen wir dort unser holz
ein bisschen aber mit prefa gerne und am
anfang ist wirklich so man tut gleich
mal ein bisschen mehr investieren
aber im endeffekt was billiger wenn du
musst ja hinweg über die jahre hinweg
keine
was kosten ja genau das heißt der es vom
haus ist wartungsfrei
während der papa fliegt ab und so die
holzteile und das war's im prinzip schon
ja ich stelle mich wieder hier rein ja
wieder auf morgen ich habe mir viel spaß
dabei hab euch ein paar ideen und paar
tipps und tricks geholt und daniela
gefällt soll ja super wir malen jetzt
noch ein bisschen bis zum nächsten mal
macht's gut weiß jemand streicher oder
einmal schwer sogar schön hier die
stunden auf schreiben versteht aber da
einmal schwer
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
und so eine prima fassade auch wenn es
so ausgesehen hat als version do it
yourself videos kann man nicht einfach
so zu dir selbst machen dafür brauchen
wir licht fachwerks betriebe und richtig
gute handwerker die auch geschult sind
da alex größer hier bei alex der wurde
jetzt bei prima auch geschult im last
zusammen und er selber zimmermanns
meister und prémat bauen meist natürlich
fachbetriebe eines ganz wichtig und
diese fachbetriebe ganz ganz wichtig
brauchen handwerker und vielleicht ist
jemand von euch gerade in der
entscheidung was im beruf wählen möchte
und handwerker sind was wirklich genial
ist alexa zerspanungsmechaniker gelernt
juni williams hat zum beispiel schlosser
gelernt hat nach einem studium gemacht
als maschinenbauer da felix hier der ist
zum beispiel garten landschaftsbau genau
wie hier dann auch alex wie gesagt hat
er ist elektriker gelernt danach hat er
zimmermann gelernt und ich bin was bin
ich eines tages nichts falsches
ich bin gelernter drucktechnologie und
verfahrensmechaniker und das sind
richtig coole handwerksberufe und
handwerker werden immer gebraucht und
auch privat auch handwerker hält den
treffer baut ja wie gesagt nur der
fachhandwerks betrieb ein
und wenn ihr wenn ihr eine kleine
außenstelle sucht gibt dem handwerk die
chance das macht auch richtig spaß oder
jährlich alex macht spaß etwas genauer
ja klar genau und es cool ist man fängt
morgens an und sieht abends was man
erreicht hat was was gestaltet unter
gemacht hat oder außer wenn du nie was
macht oder macht euch auf was du bist
also handwerk ist etwas richtig cooles
und denkt daran wir dann immer gebraucht
und ist mit die goldene zeit geben weil
jeder sucht momentan mit handwerker
kriegt sie nicht warum wenn sie alle
hier sind oder genau
ja genau will alle handwerker bei mir
sind genau und ich hoffe dass wir
dadurch gefallen
und wenn ihr noch weitere infos wollt
geht auch privat punkt.de und schaut
euch um das tolle sachen auch für uns
handwerker oder ja genau warum wir uns
für euch handwerker juni zieht sich als
handwerker würden wir sagen okay also
macht es gut viel spaß oder tschüss
[Musik]
beth ditto